y deslegitimar la validez de las
elecciones del pasado 6 de diciembre ese
fue el objetivo de la consulta popular
impulsada por la oposición venezolana
que terminó con la votación presencial
realizada este sábado a la que acudieron
más de 3.200.000 personas
creo que el gran contraste del día de
hoy es la manifestación de voluntad de
los venezolanos ejerciendo no solamente
el rechazo al fraude no solamente el
rechazo a la declaración o voluntad
férrea de avanzar por la libertad de
venezuela yo creo que lo primero la
existencia de una alternativa
democrática en venezuela mayoritaria y
no solamente mayoritaria sino organizada
desde tempranas horas llegaron los
primeros venezolanos a los 3000 centros
de votación habilitados en diversos
puntos del país
no estamos conformes con la situación
que tenemos en nuestro país por lo menos
algo debemos hacer
que mucha gente ya ni siquiera está
parando qué tipo de cosas porque ya está
escéptica frente a los resultados pero
algo hay que hacer
el disidente político leopoldo lópez
también participó en la consulta lo hizo
desde colombia donde permanece en un
intento por lograr movilizar a sus
compatriotas exiliados contra el
gobierno de nicolás maduro por eso hoy
nosotros ratificamos nuestro compromiso
a salir del dicta con salir del dictador
nicolás maduro nicolás maduro no sólo es
un dictador nicolás maduro es un
criminal
nicolás maduro ha cometido crímenes de
lesa humanidad ha hecho violaciones
severas de derechos humanos según el
comité organizador la consulta superó en
participación a los comicios
legislativos convocados por el
oficialismo en poco más de 200.000 votos
se estima que fueron más de 6 millones
466 mil electores los que respondieron a
la consulta lo que equivale al 31 como
22 por ciento del padrón electoral de la
nación petrolera sin embargo quedan
dudas ya que las cifras no fueron
constatadas por observadores y no hay
claridad sobre si quiénes votaron
presencialmente también pudieron
sufragar online